Chào hai miệng thăng tư tại Phu Trụ Tệng, tổn bị thương trực tính nước tốt lâm và phu nhận ngốc vực li đã trụ trí lấy đón trực tổn thống hạn quốc li chanh miệng, không cấp nhận nước đến Việt Nam.
Tham dự lấy đón có các đồng trí vì viên bộ chính trị, vễn vuy ngọc bị thương trường đàn trưởng bàn tổn trực trường đơn, đại tướng phán bàn dăng dăng,
có thú đường chính phủ bộ trưởng bộ cường bộ cường bộ cố phòng, tại tướng lức tàn quan bộ trường bộ công an,
đồng trí vễn thăng dị, bị thương trường đàn trưởng bàn chính xác chính lượng trường đồng trí lưu ai chông bộ trường bộ ngoại giao.
Về năng bàn quốc chính thức tế lập quan hệ ngoại giao vào ngày 22,5 năm, bộ nghiên triếp xa thứ 2.
Chào hình thăng tư, trông hình thăng quan, bối quan hệ về năng hành phút đã phát trưởng thành bối quan hệ hợp tóc bộ bởi bật và lạy hành đầu thế giới.
Đối tóc chính lực tàn dị ệnh vào tháng 22,5 năm, đế này, tình kể chính trị giãi nước ngày càng được cùng cố và tăng cường.
Hãy đến vui chỉ tốt quan hệ hệ chế tức cả thắc trên bàn chính phủ khu hội,
tụng đời mạnh mẽ thắc chuyến thâm, giao liệu tiếp dúc giữa lạng đạo thức tò hài nước.
Dện này, Việt Nam và hành cốc có nhiều cơ chế,
khuôn hộ tắc thương đối ra ra báo gồm cả hợp tắc năng ngành và hợp tắc trong lĩnh vực chuyến mồn của thế ở nhiều các độ khác nhau.
Tất hiện tế, tư mại là chục khu chính trong quan hệ hệ hành nước cũng là điểm sáng trong hợp tắc khi tế cũng tế của Việt Nam.
Hành cốc hiện là đối tác đầu tư số mồn thì chừng con cấp khách rùn định từ 2, nước con cấp o điện thí hay,
đối tác thương mại từ 3, tị trường tiếp nhận là đổn từ 3 của Việt Nam.
Chúng không?
Các nhận nước đến Việt Nam của tổn thống hành cốc đi chanh miân và phuyên giễn ra trong buổi kèng quan hệ Việt Nam
hành cốc mang ở giải đoạn phát triển tốt đẹp nhất,
tị trức đến ai, loch phần mở ra ra đoạn phát triển mới,
với những định giễn đột dài hạn trong quan hệ hành nước.